albert brewer joins us now we really
appreciate him calling in albert bear
the senior writer for sports illustrated
mmqb and albert um i should ask you
right off the bat what would be your
olympic sport should you have one what
would be your choice
i mean i think like if i go back to like
when i was a kid
and like what i had the most like
natural ability
i would say skiing because then downhill
skiing because
my mom's austrian i'm first generation
and so
like i've always been able to sort of
pick that up whenever i want to like if
i haven't done it for four or five years
it takes me like two runs and i'm like
right back to normal so
i know it probably doesn't fit with your
theme here because you guys are talking
summer olympics but it'd probably be
downhill skiing oh that's fine by me
that would be my choice a hundred
percent now what would you
never do in a million years
oh uh decathlon maybe
that doesn't sound like a lot of fun to
okay
i mean like if you talk about like what
i'd be least capable of or
where i would embarrass myself the most
probably the decathlon right
like i don't know though like because
swimming a mile sounds like pretty bad
too
like i would probably just quit in front
of everybody halfway through
you know so there are probably a few of
them that where i would i would make
myself look pretty bad
there are a lot of them out there that
you're just thinking to yourself how in
god's name are you doing this but
that's why it's fun to watch it and not
do it
absolutely absolutely you know and i i i
mean like so many of them like the
i mean the paul boss another one just
popped into my head like where it's like
it like sort of looks easy and like when
you're a kid you
you watch it and it's like i could do
that and you don't realize just how hard
that is
let's get to football because i know
nobody wants to hear me talk about pole
vaulting although now i'm totally
captivated by the idea of it
can you fill me in as to what's
happening in in houston please i feel
like we need an update with deshaun
watson what's going on
yeah so you know i i think the question
was whether or not he was gonna be
putting the exempt list and
you know i i just playing devil's
advocate here if you were
the sean washers camp and you're trying
to expedite a trade
you would try to make it as
uncomfortable in the texas as you
possibly can
and so um you know i i the the
commissioner has the power
um to put deshaun on the exempt list
he has to meet conditions and i know
if a player's camp were to push hard
against the idea
um that a guy goes on an exempt list the
league might back down
so you know my read here i think deshawn
watson and his camper trying to expedite
a trade out of houston
and i think by showing up he makes
things uncomfortable in the texans by
remaining off the exempt list
it makes things uncomfortable on the
texans and you know i can tell you susie
that
it's a difficult one because if you're
nick casario their first year general
manager
it's really really hard to sell the idea
of trading a 25 year old
franchise quarterback who signed for the
next five years
for anything less than a historic return
and right now because there's so many
questions legally and and with the
league
i i i think he's gonna have a hard time
getting everything back that he wants
and so
um yeah i think over the next few days
there's probably going to be some sort
of effort to see
what sort of attorney can get um but i
can tell you
like nicosia is pretty determined right
now not to not to give
give watson up a discount and yet at the
same time albert breer how do you
try to work out a trade for a guy that
you just don't know what's going to
happen you're putting a player out there
that could be injured at any time if he
actually does play
and if he's actually not bluffing or if
they decide to put him back out there
but how do you even figure out the trade
value when you have an
open investigation i mean at some point
yeah the commissioner could decide
to put him on the list well that's the
thing you know it's like a and you don't
know
i mean i like you know legally going
through this and i'm not
i i mean this guy like before all this
was a guy who you'd say deserve the
benefit of the doubt so i definitely
don't want to presume any sort of guilt
here
and i don't wanna on the other side of
it like completely dismissed
but i mean just we don't know you know
what i mean like i can't have a take on
what happened because i don't know
uh but yeah i mean i think there's
certainly that part of it where you know
you have the 22 lawsuits out there
um you don't know what could happen if
there's a settlement like what the next
step might be after that and then
you know you don't know what the
league's going to do so you know if
you're another team you're looking at
you're saying okay like you're a
generational quarterbacking talent 25
years old signed for the next five years
but there is that level of uncertainty
and so you know i think for each of the
teams there's that and then on top of
that
i mean cd is the one that like you got
to get ownership signed off on too
because i i know there are there are
certain teams where there's an ongoing
investigation like this happening
it's going to completely be a
non-starter no matter how good the
player is
you know and so it's tricky for a number
of different reasons for other teams
that might be considering trading for
him
and that's a huge part of why you know
like
houston getting the sort of haul back
for him
that you would expect for a player like
deshawn watson might be challenging
you know albert that's so interesting
you said that because i'm listening to
all these people opine on on radio
and on television about where he's going
to go and two of this and the other but
that's the issue is that you now have a
quarterback with a lot of money coming
in who's only 25
but 22 allegations it's not criminal it
is civil most civil does get
settled but it is a huge
gamble right now and in unprecedented
water here it looks like or an
unprecedented territory because
again it's everywhere you look at it
it's a gamble
yeah and it's and and and remember to
like the other part of it for
for an owner is this guy is the minute
he walks in the door the face here
franchise right
bigger face than the coach bigger face
than the owner bigger like the face
of your franchise is deshaun watson and
you have to be comfortable
riding through whatever's ahead with him
you know and so that's a that's a
gigantic part of it no question about it
and
you know i think that that i got like i
said like
if he gets through this like hey you
have a generational talent 25 years old
the most important position in sports
um and you haven't had them under
contract for an extended period of time
um you know and and if you get that
position settled
that can mean job security for everybody
in the building for a decade
um so you know it's just it's it's it's
it's
very very complicated and it's
complicated for teams
they're like the eagles like the
dolphins like the panthers like the
broncos um
that would absolutely be in line
for a player like this at that position
if
it weren't for everything else that was
happening albert breer joining us here
on the rich eisen show suzy schuster in
for rich eyes and let's move up to green
bay because i think that's another
let's talk about it it's only people are
really concerned about that green bay
and houston right now what do you think
is happening with aaron rodgers because
he's a guy who's a strategist he's quiet
he keeps all his cards close to the vest
what do you think is happening because
should he not show up he's bound to lose
a lot of money obviously
deshawn watson had 10.54 million reasons
to show up but
aaron rodgers is he's he's holding his
cards pretty tight
yes there's no question and i i think
there's a lot of guessing going on i
you know i don't know if they've gotten
word in the last 24 hours or whatever
but i know
there are people in the packers building
that that still didn't know
whether or not he's going to show up and
the veterans or do the report
tomorrow and um you know i i think you
nailed it susie in saying that like
everything here is strategic and um i
i think if we know aaron rodgers we know
these moves are calculated and what he's
doing and saying
none of it's by accident and so i think
you have to take what he says at face
value and what he's doing at face value
clearly there's a communication
breakdown between he and the team over
the jordan love pick
i think that that sort of brought to
light i would say a philosophical divide
between player and team that's not
unlike the divide
between brett favre and the packers 13
14 years ago which was
a star player who wants to have a voice
in the organization
and an organization that operates in a
very old school way
where they've had great players there
but they're in different categories than
management or coaches
and so um you know i how do you solve
that
i'm not sure about you know i i i think
you know that's one piece of it and then
the second piece of it is what we saw
happen over the last year in tampa and i
think this
stoked some fires in seattle as well
where
um you know i like i think players are
looking at what tom brady did and what
tom brady was able to accomplish in
tampa
and how the box built around tom brady
in almost a lebron-esque kind of way
and they say hey that's what i'm up
against and b
i want to have a situation like that and
um you know it's not just that brady got
it that way is that it works
so i think those two things are sort of
at work here both you know aaron have it
wanted to have an organization built
around him on his timeline with urgency
which is sort of the brady model now and
then number two
just the personality conflicts that i
think exists not between aaron and the
coaching staff but aaron in the front
office
no doubt and i think you you actually
hit the nail on the head there that
obviously the aryans brady relationship
and what happened
in tampa has changed things for everyone
and aaron rodgers has been around long
enough to deserve the respect and he
probably sees what brady didn't say well
i want that so the question will be now
obviously will he play out the season
in the hopes of getting that ability to
go where he wants to go next year
if you had to make a guess what would
you say
i would say there's probably some sort
of one-year band-aid
uh put on it which is another way
exactly what happened in seattle
um you know i think russell wilson came
to the conclusion
the best place for him in 2021 was going
to be in seattle
i don't think anything settled long term
there but at the very least they were
able to get russell walked into playing
this year
for the seahawks and um you know i just
think the packers are so determined not
to trade them
and susie as much as anything else it's
about the makeup of the team
right and i guess let's just take the
four quarterbacks
that have sort of been out there as guys
to be traded that are huge names that
aren't reclamation projects
um and those four are rogers wilson
matthew stafford uh
matthew stafford and deshaun watson and
i think the primary difference that a
lot of people are missing here
is the makeup of those teams detroit and
houston are rebuilding and so for those
teams it's a little easier to wrap your
head around the idea
of moving a player like that at the
packers the seahawks were in the
playoffs last year they've got a ton of
players in their prime
i i mean the right thing for those
organizations is to hang on for as long
as they can with the quarterbacks to
give the other guys in the locker room
and the coaches that are there
the best chance to compete so my guess
would be there's some sort of one
year band-aid um whether it's in the
form of a one-year raise a new contract
um this isn't about money as we've
established but as
i'm sure you know money can solve money
can be a part of the solution if even if
it wasn't part of the problem
so i think there's some sort of monetary
solution
that leads to you know maybe what some
sort of one-year fix
where if things don't change between now
and january or february
the packers and rogers are right back
where they started and of course aaron
rodgers
would be the first packer to play 17
seasons bardstar and brett farve had 16
and he's tied with that
the thing i want to point out too and
i'm curious because you know him
you know he went through the brett favre
scorned when the packers brought him in
and brett favre wanted nothing to do
with him i think it's worth noting
that he has taken jordan love under his
wing and he has tutored him and he has
helped him along he knows firsthand how
it felt to be shunned by the guy
that was threatened by him i think it
says a lot about aaron rodgers that he
has been so open
to bringing this kid along yeah i mean i
i like
i i i give him credit for that like you
know the one thing about brett favre's
approach
if you remember it was sort of like he
kind of like
detached himself from the organization
and in a way suicide almost made it
cleaner for the packers
you know like he would go down to
mississippi and they could do their
business and he'd do his business
and you know maybe he was mad but he was
away from everybody else
um aaron to his credit like hasn't you
know
taken this out on his coaches who aren't
really a part of the problem
he hasn't taken this out on his
teammates
now like that sounds great but you know
it makes for some blurred lines there
and i think you know you see what's
happening with davonte adams now
you see what's happening with the darius
smith and
i you know i think even some of the
coaches might have some divided
loyalties when it comes to this you know
so
you're right like i think that like
aaron has done a good job of not taking
this out on jordan love
or other people that aren't a pro part
of the problem that he has with the
organization
but in a funny way i think that's almost
made things a little bit
messier for the packers themselves and
you know it's a part of the transition
we saw with brady with garoppolo he
didn't want a
younger guy around either he wanted him
out of there but what's a team supposed
to do albert at some point you have to
have a plan you can't just go
it is it's not a bunch of friends it's
an organization to make money
and to win it's a hard one i'm not sure
where i would be if i were a gm i mean
if you have a talent like aaron rodgers
who's a once in a lifetime talent
you do have to have a plan though
i and i agree with that but i also think
like
in this day and age um i just think
like even if the players aren't partners
with the t like which like they really
like they aren't you know what i mean
like but
like you want to make them feel like
they're partners right
and especially quarterbacks who are
treated in so many different ways like
quasi management so
you know i think in both the situations
with brady and with rogers
if their teams had given them a heads up
right
like whether it was a week ahead of time
whatever
i think that would have gone a long way
and i can still remember with brady and
garoppolo
you know they take garoppolo i think
brady was kind of blindsided by it
and then belichick got up at his press
conference and said well we all know
tom's contract situation and age
and i mean tom was getting older but
still planning to play for a long time
and like he had consistently taken less
to stay with the team
so he was missed by that you know on top
of not getting a heads up
then it was like he trampled over him on
the way to go into trash and jimmy
garoppolo
and i think that lingered you know and i
think in a similar way here
if the packers had called aaron rodgers
a week and a half before the draft
and just said hey we really like the
utah state quarterback
i don't know if he's going to be there
but if he is there
we might get aggressive and go and get
him we want to make sure you knew
maybe he's mad in the moment but susie
if it's you
like you probably get over that quicker
right than not having heard
that having to learn while they were on
the clock that they were taking the
quarterback
like i just think there's like a human
element to this that in this day and age
you want to make those players feel like
they're almost partners
in the organization and you know you're
certainly not doing that by keeping them
in the dark and decisions like that
no and the bucks have shown exactly how
to do it i mean tom brady has put out
benjamin button has really put out a
total manual on how you can run a team
and be an effective part of it
by the way albert were you at all fooled
by that brady video that came out i mean
can you really throw a ball into a ball
machine like that
that like whoever that editor is the
video editor is there susie
sign them up because i feel like i like
i was looking for little bra and you and
i like we know what to look for in those
videos right
like i was like looking for little
breaks or little
pauses or i couldn't find anything so
i mean what if brady did that as
borderline impossible
but man like and i was actually told in
the aftermath
like it wasn't real but i mean the
editor did a good enough job
of like covering any sort of holes in
that video did you see anything i
couldn't
i i couldn't see a break i couldn't see
anything in that video
that led me to believe that it was
doctors so albert
albert i i i i texted chris brockman i'm
like oh my god he's amazing
tommy really did it yeah and he's like
susie you're so lazy
it's edited i'm like no it's not i think
i was too dazzled by the white
teeth as he walked off i don't know
tom's got a better tan than albert
i mean come on i mean i i gotta tell you
i i don't know about that like guys
those are fighting wars craig are you on
nantucket where are you right now
i'm not i was there for three weeks we
got back a couple weeks ago my dad's
still doing good though
i've always told rich that's my greatest
skill is my ability to tan
i thought you were gonna say your tan
was your best olympic sport
by the way you you do have a nice tan
gold medalist
no question well the austrian ski team
by the way
that's a you know i think that there's a
future for you albert brier in case mmqb
doesn't work out i think maybe a little
austrian skiing you get a really nice
tan the reflection from the snow
you want to send me out to the alps to
do a month or two a train to see how it
goes like i'm
totally willing to go oh i want to do a
winter olympics so badly
i just want to drink hot chocolate i
want to have the cowbell going in the
background and i want to be somewhere
with a stodd in the background i just
want to be somewhere with snow
that i can ski after do three live shots
i think that's a perfect job
albert thank you so much i really
appreciate you calling in
you got it that's albert from mmqb
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here